Oh
[Music]
hello and welcome to this video this
video is about a setup or setups where
black is playing the moves east 6 and c5
early on
I've automated decided to call that a
decline to be known yet I'm not sure
that is a right term I don't think that
these systems have a officially um
accepted name so we're talking about to
move orders to lines that often are
transposing into one another the first
one and the most common one is this one
where in this situation of course we go
g3 this is our repertoire concept when
black plays c5 so we have the typical
benoni moves so like black plays c5 to
attack the pawn and displayed this
another six and e6 which you oftentimes
see in the modern benoni if for example
instead of g3 we would have pled C form
then d5 ISM is the mainline and by far
the most common option here black it
looks like black ones have been Oni but
we even cannot play d5 so this is not
really an option here at all compare
this tomb in this water where d5 is our
choice and clearly the best move we
don't really have any good other options
besides that so right here
we cannot play d5 and it also doesn't
make all that much sense to take on c5
and black can we capture in one move the
other line that is by the way quite
related that we're going to look at is a
693 c5 and this is highly pens
positional yeah again d5 doesn't make
much sense and the only move here that
would fit into our repertoire concept
here is to move g3 of course to delay
the c4 pawn move and yeah now except
that black takes on D form that is not a
big deal at all that black is able to
take on d4 we have seen a lot of this
concept when
we looked at the reversed guru felt
which is oftentimes starting like this
when lag takes on deformed in fact the
reverse Greenfeld and these lines they
have something they have lots of trans
positional um and value let's say these
lines because let's say c5 g3 whenever
plague plays d5 we have a transposition
into the reverse Greenfeld and in fact
this happens very often in particular if
the black player is somewhat aia rated
and is doing it's playing in this
process water for this particular reason
now I'd like to start with with this
move order in particular black playing
east six first and then c5 first of all
I need to emphasize that this is not
going to happen very frequently in your
games that particular move order like
playing six and z5 is not such an easy
line for black to employ because they
have to be basically ready to play a
French defense I mean we're not going to
play you for but they have to be ready
for that
and if they play c5 they even have to
anticipate that somebody could play a
four which all of a sudden is an open
Sicilian so the black player here needs
to be very very versatile in its opening
repertoire this is the reason why not
many players play this with black and
therefore I don't think you will face it
so frequently now we are going to play G
3 of course and now see what happens I
need to say that I'm covering this line
rather extensively for one particular
reason there's one critical line that
black may play and this is yeah giving
white the option to play very
dynamically and these dynamic lines are
think are very instructive to understand
how dynamics work in positions with d4
Knight a3 g3 it's not by any stretch of
the imagination a lame opening that we
are playing there are in fact many
dynamic possibilities and this is a good
showcase for the
so even though I mentioned I don't think
you will get it on the board often it's
interesting to study also for general
chess purposes not just because ok that
could be an opening that you could play
against you now I need to say that in
many cases black we'll just play Knight
f6 and transpose into the yeah main line
of this chapter d4 Knight f6 Knight e3
e6 g3 c5 them so the transposition of
possibilities here are endless and I'm
not going to say on every single
occasion now night I have six would
transpose this is something that just
applies to almost every position now
that we look in yep black most of the
time actually plays Knight f6 or takes
on D form taking on d4 is most
frequently seen however he can do many
other things that we should check
briefly um there are moves with some
independent value here but they are
dealt with rather quickly in fact now
what can they do black could play d5
yeah that is a direct transposition
after Bishop g2 into the reverse Grune
felt after C takes on line f6 so we
leave this chapter and the transposes to
UM a different one blank could play and
that has says happening rather often
surprisingly b6 and mix this is 65 with
the Queen's Indian with the Queen's
Indian twist um this is not a very
precise move order on a slave because
White has two dangerous options that you
could check out but I don't really feel
they are worth analyzing all that much
because it's such a rare move order the
simplest recipe here is to play Bishop
g2 a way to try to punish black for this
move order would be to play e4 and go
into some sort of Sicilian like after
this and this we have basically a
Sicilian and this is probably quite good
for white but also far away from what we
are usually playing so I recommend
Bishop g2
now black will probably play Bishop d7
opposed the bishop and now the keep it
simple option is to simply take on c5
and to transpose after Bishop takes or
partakes and castles into the Queen's
Indian chapter this is how we play in
the Queen's engine and it is absolutely
feasible here as well as just a
transposition and if you are interested
in analyzing young very sharp
complications you can check out the
engine suggestion a forum this is I
think how you could possibly refute to
this Bishop b7 - b6 Bishop d7 stuff but
this is a very sharp pawn sacrifice I
looked at this a little bit but I felt
this would simply blow up the chapter to
unreasonable proportions for a very very
rare move order so if you face this
without any particular preparation time
where you want to go if warrant kill
your opponent immediately just take on
c5 entrance polls it's the economical
way to do things
similar leave I would recommend after b5
which is also rare but still it has been
played I would recommend to simply play
Bishop g2 and angle for transposition
into a B 5 based setup that has a
separate chapter um of course you can
look at a form and so on sharp stuff but
you know this is so rare if it happens
let's say in a rapid game in a blitz
game you need a quick decision play
Bishop g2 and just as opposed after
Bishop d7 castles for example Knight f6
Bishop g5 we have as posed into the
chapter on early b5 systems this is the
I think the sensible thing to do and
going back to the position here after 3
g3 just a moment
um there's another move that is largely
transpositional that is Knight to c6 we
play Bishop g2 and now black will
probably take on d4 and play Knight f6
or play Knight f6 straight away and this
would transpose into the more standard
move order of this concept for black one
Knight f6 c6 then C five so knight c6 is
very independent or very few independent
lines at all and a move that is also
transpositional but should be checked
just to be aware that it exists is Queen
to a5 check this little looks a little
bit odd but it has a point we don't
really want to play him of course Queen
d2 or so it looks very lame Knight bTW -
also a little bit lame um
I suspect or i am i think that c3 is to
move to play here the reason is that I
think at a later stage we are still able
to play c4 in 93 in general I'm not a
huge fan of playing c3 all that often in
our repertoire because it's mostly not
you have the most active move what I
want with a move like c3 I want the
clear idea why I'm doing this um and not
just okay let's play on this movement
it's it's a it's a slow edge kind of
setup yeah it is not a problem at all
because later we get to place
[Music]